um
quick breakdown cube fanatics is maxed
out 150 out of 150
uh war zone rated as usual
1736 average rating time handicap 30
minutes here we go game one of how many
double those points get this thing out
of here
quickly it's
it's not moving quickly
um this is different maybe i should go
with this actually in response to the
sicilian
because it's setting up for what
you know it
you know it don't make me say it
i'll say it anyway but
fishing you know you want a castle and i
know that my opponent is going to be
well aware of it
because they are a stream watcher
a stream watcher the center is built the
bishop is
bearing right down on h
setting it up it's engaged
rook b1
i'm on the queen
guard upon you know you want a castle
i don't want a castle just castle
just castle
my opponent is being stubborn quit being
stubborn
get out of there queen
time burners
my bishop's around
what am i doing
um
i'm trying to make it work i just
dropped my queen no
you kidding me
no
say it isn't so
wait a second
oh
this is not good i gotta do time burners
i just drop my queen
oh they dropped their queen for a rook
that's what i get that's what you get
for trying to oh there goes another rook
oh
the tables turn
hang on hang on hang on
what a bad start
what a bad start
wow
wow
what a bad start time burners time
burners time burners where the time
burners push upon
back to tournament that took forever
shame on me
shame on me for trying to sneak in the
fishing pole
wow
i was trying to go uh fishing
um with just like the regular fishing
line
through like uh
i don't know what i'm getting at here
anyhow it wasn't there don't do it if
it's not there you fool
okay
it might be here though
it still might be here
no it's not quite there
all right let's get on this diagonal
light squares light squares light
squares i'm on that pawn twice
um
okay let's not do that
okay let's defend rook over here defend
a little bit more
okay pawn pushes no maybe i want to do
this
why did i do that move
i don't know why
i don't know why i did that move let's
come back here
okay this is a bit uh scary very very
scary more than a bit
more than a bit it just is scary oh boy
uh oh uh oh i almost mouse slipped right
there i think
just take that i'm okay with double
pawns i think
um
is this okay
this is so tough
rook where rook right here hit that pawn
look up
okay shut that night down that pond
falls though
is this gonna be okay i'm so so passive
over here
can we trade
let's trade because you're up material
trade would trade when you're up
material not down material
and i'm moving quick what's the time
situation i have to use
i have to call upon my best friend again
again i have to call upon my best friend
oh what is my king up to
what is he up to
my best friend if you did not know
is the clock that's all i have it's the
clock
that's all i have ever
ever
time burners where are you is this gonna
work out somehow
pass pawn
uh-oh
gotta take that guy
my bishop my bishop my bishop no time
no time no time i gotta
i just swallowed some of my um
unchewed granola actually it wasn't
granola it was a nature valley
anyhow same thing um that fuel that i um
uh you know what i'm getting at i was
gobbling up on some nature valley peanut
butter stuff
and it was showing showing up just then
here we go
let's go here
you could make it happen
make it happen
forks forks forks forks forks
i got a rook
back to tournament
let's go here 17 12. no surprise
mr cap is up there let's close that out
that was a quick win less than 25
minutes
somebody's saying the nature valley
gambit sneaky sc2 i caught that one corn
in my eye that was that was almost a
nature valley gambit right there
you gotta watch out for those those are
deadly they will oh just take a bishop
if the bishop is free take it
quit your pre-moves there's another one
okay
is is everything gonna be all right here
let's do this
let's get the night out oh there's gonna
be tricks right here
oh why'd i just do that oh okay okay
okay okay okay
is this all right
please say it's all right why did i do
that oh did i cringe as soon as bishop
here because that would be three pawns
for the piece and my king would be
running around
oh okay i think everything's all alright
though right now
i better get this frog on my throat
this is not good i need some water i
have to somehow factor in some water
here um
in between
games okay let's get castle before you
get killed
i could grab that palm but i really
don't want to do that
um
i can't talk
i can't talk there's so it's got my
throat i didn't i didn't chew it good
enough
come on my pony isn't moving maybe this
is a this is time to um
to uh to grab that water bishop b5 i
just back up i don't want my clock to
burn time burners
just time burner variation
they're being sneaky
time burners anything anything do not
let my clock tick back to tournament 20.
quick
let's go
all right
um
whoa what is this the a pawn attack the
rook up and over variation whoa
rook up and over no one will suspect
that one never
the crazy rook
that rook is clearly gone bonkers right
there
is he having a field day he's getting a
workout that rook
he's having fun
what's
the scoop with that oh this is the
kitchen sink variation
they're throwing the kitchen sink at me
i know all about this one my bishop
wants to play on this diagonal
i better win this one after that wacky
after that wacky start oh this is oh
definitely kitchen sink everywhere
kitchen sink
wow discovered tricks everywhere
discovered tricks right here
mate
it's me it's mate back to tournament 39
30.
double that dice
dr bravo
um
i gotta move the stream
okay
i think uh
take that free piece
why am i never taking my own advice here
take free pieces
free pieces
um
back to tournament that was a quick win
quick win 42 39 20 20.
let's go oh i thought this was kappa
rock it looked like that it's a
cat
it's not cap it's cat
i'd have three i'm gonna mask it it's
being masked right now it's in disguise
the fishing pole is in disguise right
now oh they sniffed it out
they sniffed out that one or did they
where's the night gonna go you know you
want to go right here knight
oh is this still working is it
it might be working
somehow just take that knight he's juicy
you know you want to take him yes they
did want to take him
check here it's happening again
it's happening again
go fish everybody loves to go fish
okay 56 53
it's free point edge seven games in each
a lot of time left
20 minutes 10
9
20 minutes and change zero
1991.
uh zero 1991 is the handle
with the 1951
uh rating so
let's go let's go for it
is it gonna be sniffed out yet
is the fishing pole gonna be
extinguished
oh
okay um
anti-fishing pool i am insisting on
getting that uh pawn though
i could take the pawn no i want to get
here with my knight good things happen
when you go to um weak points in your
opponent's position oh
but what if they do that
you gotta run away scared i didn't
really i really don't want to push that
pawn and maybe they'll just take the
bait take the bait he's free is he
forks and stuff
watch out for the forks i might try
something sneaky here
i'm on that rook
um i'm gonna try something sneaky
hopefully my opponent falls for it this
is not something i would do in a regular
game but i'm gonna try and be sneaky
with a mate and two threat i want my
queen on d7
oh it doesn't work actually i better
take somebody down with it the queen is
defending that pawn
that's what you get that's what you get
oh i gotta hide behind this pawn
can i make this work
get out of there bishop
get out of there bishop
what's my queen going to do now
oh i only have 16 seconds this is bad
why is this so bad
i can't defend this i don't have any
time oh man
oh this is bad this is bad this is bad i
need time burners anything
just take that i'm on the bishop
trade trade trade trade trade trade
trade watch out for sneaky stuff oh
sneaky stuff right around the corner
come on you could do it you could do it
you could do it you could do it you
could do it you just lost your rook
run for the hills pond run for the hills
grab this go here give a check grab a
rook
grab a rook grab a rook the queen is on
the scene how much time how much time
i have time okay i was holding my breath
again 72 69 40.
hugh
is having uh okay he resigned he
resigned 81 69 i think it was a he
i don't know
double the points sicilian land again
and
a non-mover i could use a non-mover
right now
make sure
i could definitely use the non-mover
right there okay
that was a well-timed non-mover
okay what's going on elsewhere
in um
tournament land here
um okay where's my nearest rival i'm
gonna do homework home cooking
home cooking come on why you could do it
or not you're really down on time aren't
you
white's up white's up lights up but look
at how much time i know that feeling
i know that feeling
ah just no time to win
time burner city
and this guy is not moving
i'm getting uh
killed here with this uh
okay 12 seconds uh what's what's the
what's the count here what's the
leaders leaders i'm in i'm in second i'm
in second
or am i i'm going to get some points for
this i think i'll be up three
after this give me give me give me give
me give me up ten up ten up ten
ninety one i'm up four
i got ten games in
nine is in second here we go e4
let's go you can do it you can do it you
can do it oh what is going on with this
oh man the the creepy crawler variation
what do you call this it's the creepy
crawler variation
oh get out there bishop
you need to go somewhere else oh he's
not going somewhere else he should have
ran back home he was too good for his
home
the night is cooked
uh oh this is getting ugly
isn't it pieces are falling everywhere
the knights landing checks the king's
running scared
the queen is cooked the king is running
for the hills the king is close to dead
the rook is beat up
and there's a mate right around the
corner next just move yes back to
tournament 111 107.
uh-oh 15 minutes and change we're about
halfway there
leo
leo
leo leo leo open sicilian leo
a6 support that queen position you know
what i'm going for has this person seen
it
do they know what i have up my sleeve do
they know what i have up my sleeve it's
engaged the line has been cast and the
bait is hooked
the bait is hooked mate in one threat
has been parried but i am persistent i
will crash through it's back on h2 be
very scared it's defend it again
regroup
sit back relax build up
hit f7 since it's weakened
why not f7 is weak hit that f7 point get
on f3 maybe hit the queen one day if she
goes to e2 or the rook
or
f3 forks right around the corner the
queen is ready to be cooked move rook
go back oh
okay i'll take this and then bail out
here
no i didn't i thought the queen was
gonna recapture
a pre-move i was caught in a pre-move
now i just have to do what
just open this up
open this up this could this could uh be
really good really soon
queenside castle double rooks and then
it's mate
grab that pawn
i don't care about my g pun
i just want to double
double rooks double trouble
pins
let's play here
we're just going to dance back and forth
knight f4 and stuff like that
oh my queen's hit i don't care there's
no there's no time
they don't have any time
no time just burn the time
no time just burn the time okay back to
tournament all these seconds count
precious seconds 131 127
okay
we could get paired up at any moment
here
any moment here okay let's get rid of
that dark square bishop and then
well not so fast let's see what they're
going to do in the center okay they're
not going to do anything in the center
if that e pawn was pushed this is not a
good idea to do the bishop h6 if this
pawn was here and the queen has h4
available
okay let's come here i got a weasel
around here
come on move knight i don't have any
time this guy is flying
this guy is
in another gear right here
get out of there night oh
they did a pre-mover
what is that move doing oh my bishop
would come out
that's what it's doing give a check get
your knight off of the c1 square he's
not happy about being there
let's develop queens are going to come
off the queens are off
this night is going to be a pain right
here he's a giant pain
now he's not
night check is okay okay this is a
support point it's a good support point
and my rook
wants to get active let's go activity
for the rooks
oh
okay i'm gonna give that guy up actually
and i shouldn't have given him up
don't you dare fall for a fork i'm gonna
scream if that happens
don't you dare
okay i think um
i think things are okay right now
kill this knight because he's trapped
that's why it's okay
just kill the knight if he goes here
and push that pawn away let's go let's
go whoa
see how it's just stuck on my pawn there
what did i do to deserve that
um double up no just keep pushing away
let's trade a little bit just a hair
oh
okay pigs one pig on the seventh
two pigs on the seventh
looking for mates and that's mate that's
what happens when you have pigs on the
seventh mate and
gobble up pieces and stuff
177.
no don't you dare where the where are
the quick resigners
i need some quick resigners
is this the guy that threw the kitchen
sink at me last time
it might have been
is he gonna give me all his pieces
oh the queen's looking to kill me
ah she's looking to get beat up she's
definitely looking for a beating by
coming out like that
ah this is the kitchen sink
this is the kitchen sinker
let's grab a rook
are they just going to walk into a maze
is that oh yeah it is the kitchen sink
yes back to tournament fairly quick
resigners 177
171 and 90 is the next one
it's a neck and neck battle here 11 less
than 11 here
oh
let's go let's go let's roll come on
let's go e4
d4
gambit city
grab a pawn
help out the development
that's what gamuts do
they help speed up your own development
most of the time the knight is running
in reverse
a reverse night maneuver
let's play here
now let's not play there let's just move
just move here pile up on that knight
recapture here
pinned piece is powerless
let's go here i really don't want to
uh capture i want well i do want to
capture my pawn
knight c3 okay what's the plan pawn push
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
i don't know what that's doing exact
exactly but
oh light square weaknesses
light square weaknesses i should
probably get castle soon
oh they were fearing the worst right
there they didn't want a castle queen
side castle here i don't want the queens
to come off
no
no i don't want the queens to come off
don't you dare my knight wants to be
right here deadly check incoming deadly
check deadly check the king has to come
out he's got to be real scared i could
grab that rook but i like my night too
much
oh
deadly discovery check
this is a problem
this is a resign time
resign time
come on you know this is resign time
down on time and position
don't be a clock burner
grab here
hit the queen i could take the queen
right now
where's the mate
where's that mate
oh what
okay this game isn't going to finish
they're not resigning anytime soon
they're not resigned back to tournament
130
130 where i get that from 207 191
jonathan
cm c5 for the win
what's the scoop what's the scoop a
quick resigner that's what i needed boom
211
yes eight minutes and change a timely
quick resigner are we going to get
paired up
myself in the capster
hang on alkynes
hang on
and let's roll here let's roll my bishop
is engaged he's pointing right where he
wants to point
and
black just needs to castle and then good
things happen for team white
come on you know you want a castle
let's chop this knight up
and let's weasel around over here hang
on rook don't you dare let's grab this
pawn i think it's important
and uh post up oh oh
let's go here my knight wants to be on
g6
he's liking the g6 square okay queen
side castle or not okay well let's block
that i want a castle don't stop me from
castling
let's get out of a pin
king right here i think he's going to be
happy with that and let's get here
and
here i want to shut the door on that
bishop but then this pawn becomes weak
so not really
my bishop should probably get to a um
actually let's do this i'm thinking more
about it now
okay now it ran away voluntarily time oh
i just dropped a pawn let me give a
check
they're probably expecting a recapture
let's not do that though
pressure clock situation i don't have
get over there
let's come back here let me i'm trying
to come up with something i don't have
anything i should probably grab that
rook take three pieces how many times i
have to tell myself
take free pieces and get out of tricky
stuff you just hung a knight i could
have taken a bishop as well let's do it
now
oh ooh why'd i do it with my king like
crazy
clearly
clearly crazy with that move
let's just take here defend defend
defend pre-move city
pre-move anything anything anything
checks here more checks over here back
to tournament they're down on time 237
one he's got eighteen i have seventeen
are we gonna get paired up
that'll be for all the marbles
it'll be for all the marbles i would
think
get down to the wire here i should have
thrown in queen to b6 let's go h pawn
save the day
you can do it just grab that pun
go after this guy
or the bee pun
let's get castled queen side
queenside castle take that knight okay i
have the g file to play with g file save
the day
push in the center kick that knight
around a little bit
get out of there tonight
let me grab this pawn
okay my king is a little bit uh
okay let's come over here can i get this
oh
pin that knight the queen can give a
check that might be pretty good queen
check to get out of the pin
then i get in tempo with rook c8 i want
to play okay that knight is still in the
pin that can't be too comfortable
no way that could be comfortable the
queen is not a happy camper right now
she's not a happy camper
okay is this quick resign come on
let's do this so i can play here
otherwise bishop takes there
f5
let's go i want to get at f2
bishop takes pawn is available now but
now it isn't
f2
oh
okay take that pawn i get the rook
where's the mate where is that mate it's
happening soon you know you wanna you
know you know you wanna go to the corner
you know you wanna go to the corner yes
he went to the corner that's me they're
down on time no they resigned 251 i have
a lead
251-237 but
second place cap is probably ready to
win his game five minutes and change
okay sicilian let's try this the alpine
d6 we saw this earlier with a five
minute standard game let's get developed
like this and like this and try to get
an e5 can i make that work
maybe
maybe what are what are they going to do
bishop g4 do i want to block with the
bishop or the knight okay they're not
they're not oh why didn't i didn't mean
to do that
ah
man come on castle
i'm setting it up
setting it up the knight's gonna play
here uh let's get my rook here
and
you know you want to just castle right
now you know it's safe to castle you
know it's safe to castle you know it's
safe to castle actually there's nothing
here
there's absolutely nothing here i don't
this the square is covered
and now i can't castle my king has to
run for the hills
running for the hills right here and
that light square bishop what's
happening here
oh
okay i see the tricks
i was ready to play here let's not do
that
let's not do that because that would be
mate
and let's not do that because you'd lose
your rook what's the time situation oh
man i gotta go here and it's not good
it's not happening how much time
oh i just gotta take this i need time
burners that's all i have once again
time is my best friend
once again that's all i have time
oh man why didn't i take the queens
please don't say it's me please please
just trade the queens trade the queens
it's going to be safe okay is it gonna
be safe
no no no no don't do that
why aren't they taking it why aren't
they taking my queen oh no i could just
recapture i wasn't gonna do that though
because they hesitated i was ready to
play my bishop there you see what
happens when you hesitate
don't hesitate
i wasn't even gonna take that guy back
hit a rook
clock situation where we at i just grab
a rope take free stuff they're in check
now they don't have time
wow so much missed stuff here
unreal grab this pun play here look for
mate the bishop wants to move you know
you want to move bishop you definitely
don't want you know you want to move and
it's not even mate
it's not even made but let's just do
that
time situation time situation
is there don't check the server they're
down on time there's no checking needed
okay back to tournament 271
oh they slipped back somebody got cap
who beat cap
i was ready to resign right there
227 can i get in one more game
uh oh they're going with the creepy
crawler creepy crawler variation the
queen is excited about shifting over
like that
doing like uh i don't know what you call
that
she's doing a little slide right there
the sliding technique she's using
okay upon falls dark square weaknesses
203 i want to get here give a check
it's not happening though i want to
break down the center
center's going to be broken down it's
broken down broken down center the
knight has these squares
the queen is gonna be
uh maybe kicked around a little bit uh
where okay come over here it's safe over
here queenside castle this might be a
problem
stop it
no let's just take here
give a check queenside
castle and oh just just push here i
should have done that
i thought the queen could play here i
can't push here otherwise it's mate
let's do this first oh i have this
i still have it though my rook is on it
now
with check with check with check with
check and then hit the queen then i'm on
the rook where's the mate
where's the mate where's the fork
one minute one minute eleven
one minute eleven come on
oh come on this is so beat isn't it
just move bishop go somewhere
get out there night
and
this
and then where's the mate the bishop you
know you want to move
where's the mate
really really soon
queen here
here
that's mate that's me that's me back
determined 291 273 oh if he gets 20 if
he gets another win he's gonna be ahead
no don't you dare win would he get 20
points or would it be something less
because he uh fell back
i gotta win this
can i win this i only have 30 seconds
what's what is it what is it what is it
what is it what is it yes i'll take it
oh they called it really quick
first place confetti i'm gonna take that
confetti
oh
okay
wow they called that one quick i thought
it said 40 seconds left
oh
good games oh
291 273 180
175 top three there get the confetti and
the little trophy